شكرا لك محمد ونواصل كما ذكرت تغطيه
الاحداث والتطورات التي بدات عصر اليوم
وفي تطور الاحدث ذكرت القناه الرابعه عشره
الاسرائيليه ان نتنياهو وكبار المسؤولين
في الدفاع والاجهزه الامنيه قرروا في
اجتماع طبيعه الرد على الهجوم الصاروخي من
لبنان وموقعه اما اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي
فقالت ان التقييم الاولي هو انه هجوما في
غزه ولبنان سيحدث الليله وبعد الاجتماع
قال نتنياهو ان اسرائيل ستضرب اعدائها
وسيدفعون ثمنا لعدوانهم واضاف ان الخلافات
الداخليه لن تمنع الاسرائيليين من مواجهه
اعدائهم على كل الجبهات ودعا في نفس
الاثناء الى تهدئه التوترات وقال انه
سيعمل بحزم ضد المتطرفين الذين يستخدمون
العنف واشار الى انه لا رغبه لديه في
تغيير الوضع الراهن للاماكن المقدسه في
القدس وقد علقت هيئه البث الاسرائيلي على
كلامي نتنياهو بالقول ان عدم توجيهه
اتهاما لاي احد امر لافته